- Ladies and gentlemen,
a woman who I find to be one
of the most arresting women
who has ever lived on this earth
and a woman who's not afraid
to be arrested, Jane Fonda.
(audience applause)
- Hi Drew, I'm so happy to see you.
- Oh god, I'm so happy to see you too.
I know I'm supposed to
be asking you questions
but oh my God, I love you so much.
- Well, we've known each
other for a long time.
I mean, here I am sitting
in a kind of a basement room
that I fixed up and you're in a studio.
You're really doing this serious
and I'm so excited for you.
- Thank you.
Can I show and share a
TikTok that everybody
has already seen and
it went totally viral?
But it's you and quarantine
and I love this video so much because
I think when things get heavy,
you try to find the
window of appropriateness
to bring in a sense of humor.
I mean, look at you.
I love you so much.
(laughing)
It's just, this is so fun.
I've been to your house for a
party, by the way, that was,
your parties, by the way everybody,
Jane Fonda parties are epic.
- I remember well.
You came with Chelsea Handler.
- I did.
- And she was in a did terrible mood.
(audience laughter)
- I kind of also like
separated and did my own thing.
That's the thing, I'm a solo bird.
You have a full blown disco in your house.
It's like, it's got lights.
Like it looks like a disco.
- Yeah, well that was my ex
lover and a different house,
and I don't do that anymore.
- But see what that relationship
brought you, a disco.
- It brought me a disco
and a few other things too.
- Recently you said that
you're swearing off men.
Can I please talk to you about this?
Cause I think I'm there
and have been there
for the last five years.
Why am I here?
Why are you here?
What's happening?
- You're so young.
You're too young to swear off anything.
You gotta stay open to anything, Drew.
I'm too old so it's very easy to swear off
getting undressed, even in candlelight.
- Your argument though was so good.
You were talking about your
full life and your friends
and your kids and your
philanthropic endeavors
and your work and your life
is so full and I think-
- Who has time?
(audience laughter)
- Yes!
This is where I've been at.
No, listen, I'm not closed for business,
but I have been exactly in that mentality
for the last five years thinking,
I just don't have the bandwidth.
I don't know if I'm willing to open my,
I just don't, I just, I can't fit it in!
(laughing)
- Well, you can squeeze a
little affair or two in there.
I'm all for it.
- I love your whole life.
I loved Jane "In Five Acts"
and when you're an activist
and there are so many things going on
and so many battles to choose,
how do you choose one and
have the courage again,
to go out there and get
on the bullhorn about it?
- Let me give you a metaphor
that may help you okay,
because you and I, and the
so many of us celebrities
think a lot about, what
is our role in the crises?
You know, do we have a right to speak out
'cause we're attacked a lot when we do?
But think of it this way.
You know those antennas that
are on the top of mountains?
There're antennas that stick
up, they're called repeaters.
And what they do is, they pick
up the voices in the valley
that aren't quite strong enough to
make it up over the mountain,
and they lift the voices up
to give them a wider audience.
So that's what you are.
All you are, is a repeater,
so you just have to be as
good or repeater as you can.
- Well, "Time" magazine
said that your book would be
the most anticipated book of the fall.
You were able to put into
words the climate crisis
that made it feel like there is hope.
- Well, there is hope.
I mean the scientists who
lay out the dire warnings,
they all say, but we can do it.
We have the technology to do it.
We have the money to do it.
We have everything that we need,
except the numbers of people.
We just need more people.
- One thing I've always loved and admired
is a life truly lived,
and I can't think of anyone on this planet
who has lived a more
extraordinary life than you.
And
- Oh goodness.
- And I think I'll always,
in the presence of greatness,
feel like I've never met you,
I just stand on there
and stare at you in awe.
But I do know you a little bit.
I'm so happy to know you.
- You're talking like
this is coming to an end.
Is this over?
I hope not.
- I suppose so, but I just know this.
I'm not going to that death bed
without milking every moment
and seeing everything and telling everyone
how much I love and admire them,
because I gotta get out
of this life knowing that
I put my heart out there
and you have had my heart,
my whole life and will continue to do so.
- Oh thanks Drew.
This is gonna be a huge hit,
this show that you're doing.
I'm really happy for you.
- Thank you.
You're ensuring that by
your presence because
your lifelong credibility is because of
everything that you've
done and accomplished
and not talked about, but, action.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
"Time" magazine's, the must read of 2020.
Pick your copy up and find your hope.
- Aww thanks.
- Thank you, Jane.
(audience applause)
- Thank you for coming
on the show (screams).
- How much I love you, bye.
- I love you, oh my God, okay.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)